en une fraction de seconde l'explosion
l'aéroport divano france vista l'ouest
de l'ukraine vient d'être touché par des
frappes russe plus à l'est c'est celui
de chung f qui est visé une épaisse
fumée noire se dégage du site des lots
en ukraine des explosions ont retenti un
peu partout dans le pays
ce que j'en pense c'est terrible c'est
horrible on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer ensuite
l'est de l'ukraine mais aussi kiev ou
encore odessa tout le pays a été
attaquée par la russie qui dit ne viser
que des sites militaires
mes atouts gaiffe près de kharkiv les
habitants constatent que ces immeubles
sont aussi touchés plusieurs personnes
sont blessées
la maison est complètement détruite
il n'y a plus de fenêtres plus de porte
une porte a même été soufflé le sol a
été complètement arrachée je suis juste
très chanceuse je dois avoir un ange
gardien très fort pour être encore dit
le président volodymyr zelensky a
proclamé la loi martiale et en appel aux
volontaires mouchet venez y distribuer
ont déjà des armes et une continuerons à
en distribuer pour défendre notre pays à
tout ce qu'ils veulent et qu'ils ont la
capacité de défendre notre souveraineté
le futur de l'ukraine dépend de chaque
citoyen
dans la capitale les sirènes anti
bombardements ou longuement résonné
les gares stations de métro ont été
prises d'assaut d'autres tentent de fuir
par la route donnant lieu à ses
embouteillages monstres
[Musique]
à partir de 6h ce matin tout le monde a
commencé à s'activer a tenté de quitter
kiev mais il y avait énormément de monde
et c'est impossible de fuir l'ukraine en
ce moment
plus à l'est à g à tort sq les files
d'attentes s'allongent devant les
distributeurs
je pense qu'il n'y aura bientôt plus
l'électricité plus d'eau
ce sera en fait comme en 2014
car ici les troupes russes ne sont qu'à
quelques kilomètres après être entré en
ukraine par la crim est annexée par la
russie il y a huit ans à marioupol ces
véhicules et équipements militaires
n'ont pas résisté aux affrontements